( intro music )
Information only becomes
meaningful
when you've had
an experience.
How do you really bring
that experience of science
to people all around the world?
A big vision that
we have is to bring
a microscope into the pocket of
every single kid in the world.
It's about getting to
places where
these tools
would never go.
This is a girl that
I met in Nigeria.
And I showed her for
the very first time
how mosquitoes
actually feed blood.
We found a fellow friend
there was a mosquito
biting him right there
we caught it
we put it under our microscope,
and we actually showed
blood cells inside the
gut of that mosquito.
This girl had a completely
different perspective.
And the next day,
when she went back home
she actually slept
under a bed-net.
That's the perception
that you want
when you're trying to bring
science and technology
into people's hands.